good evening I'm here on behalf of the
Board of Governors and the actors branch
of the Academy to kick off our final
presentation of this magical evening as
you know the governor's awards are a
chance for the Academy to recognize
unique achievements across an artist
whole body of work because Jackie Chan
the man who puts the Chan in Chan tastic
because he has worked mostly in martial
arts films and action comedies two
genres that have been for some reason
shall we say historically
underrepresented at the Oscars a fact
that will change if I have any pull on
the Board of Governors
it is especially gratifying to be able
to acknowledge Jackie's enormous
creativity his great dish for physical
performance an incredible dedication to
his work with this Governor's Award
tonight great acting comes in many
different forms but if you are an actor
you always know it when you see it now
Jackie Chan's films had been incredibly
serious sometimes gruesomely so as well
as incredibly hilarious to the point of
delighting millions of people's around
the globe on one hand you could say out
of China came another version of John
Wayne the serious films and out of China
came the Buster Keaton the comedic films
how is this possible out of one man his
talents must be truly Chan tastic
but Jackie does something that neither
one of those great Skrill screen legends
was ever able to do neither one of those
great great artists of the cinema ever
put the bloopers on during the closing
credits and those outtakes never showed
John Wayne or Buster Keaton fracturing
his elbow or tearing his planters
fasciae and that's just one of the many
reasons why the actors branch is so
pleased to be honoring Jackie the chan
tastic chan along with the rest of the
Academy Jackie Chan
[Applause]
[Music]